mientras oficializaba su cargo de rey
del reino unido- carlos tercero se
enfadó y le hizo este gesto despectivo a
uno de sus empleados para que le
apartara una bandeja de bolígrafos
mientras firmaba unos documentos una más
de las muchas polémicas en las que se ha
visto envuelto el ahora monarca durante
toda su vida la primera y quizás la más
sonada fue la infidelidad a su primera
esposa la princesa diana- con la actual
reina consorte camila
[Aplausos]
un episodio que acabó con el matrimonio
y lo hizo un muy impopular entre los
británicos
éramos tres en el matrimonio así que
estábamos un poco apretados a pesar de
que carlos siempre ha defendido la
protección del medio ambiente
inglés
no podemos ser menos que valientes y
revolucionarios con la crisis climática
si no lo hacemos el resultado será
catastrófico para nosotros pero los más
pobres del mundo serán los más afectados
por esto el rey se ha visto envuelto en
entramados graves como cuando se le
acusó de cohecho o corrupción cuando el
periódico the sunday times publicó que
en 2013 aceptó una donación de miembros
de la familia de osama bin laden por más
de un millón de libras esterlinas para
su fundación de caridad no obstante
quizás en la acusación más grave que
recae sobre el ahora monarca en su
intento de influir en la política
británica en 2015 se destapó que había
recibido documentos confidenciales del
gobierno por décadas con demandas
personales como permisos para pesca si
legales
no creo que carlos vaya a generar gran
entusiasmo como rey todas sus polémicas
no reflejan o representan una cara
fresca para la monarquía país o demovic
es un conjunto de factores que han hecho
del rey de reino unido uno de los
miembros menos populares de la familia
real británica